this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you very tech and Thank
You Adrienne for the invitation it's a
pleasure to be here and indeed I so I'm
going to talk about a plant development
so not my audience left to feel a little
bit in the years maybe I will come back
to it Adam okay so my question today is
how do plants with their own shape it's
might be a bit of a cryptic question but
it's a way to address the role of
mechanical signals in developments but I
guess it's going to be clearer with the
presentation so one thing that I need to
use one thing is for sure is that
there's a lot of data in the literature
showing that cells are able to sense the
mechanical environment and one thing for
instance is that if you saw this is all
in animals if you grow a single cell on
the micro pattern like this you can
actually predict the orientation of the
spindle and the next division and this
is due to the fact that because if the
adhesion pattern is biased by the
pattern when you biased also the spindle
but this is the force within the cell
that is guiding the the spindle
orientation another thing that has been
shown also for cell division is that if
you compress or stretch the cell you're
going to accelerate or decelerate
the Mitel mitotic progression okay so
that's one example that there's another
one that is maybe even stronger I would
say if you grow stem cells so
mesenchymal stem cells on substrate so
this it has exactly the same chemical
composition the only difference is the
stiffness of the substrate so if you
grow those stem cells on soft matrices
you get a neuro blast if you grow the
same stem cell on the stiff matrix you
get an osteoblast so it means that the
mechanical environment or in this case
the matrix is defining the cell fate in
this case and what's also interesting is
that so you have this relation with
stiffness but the entire cell is
actually changing so if you grow both
stem cells they're going to have a more
dense
extracellular matrix
to have more cytoskeleton and even the
nuclei is going to become the nucleus is
going to become stiffer on stiffer
medium
so you completely reprogram the cell
based on the mechanical environment of
this cell okay so this is at the single
cell level and there's a lot of data at
the single cell level there's fewer data
at the multi cellular level of course
because it's much more difficult to
address and it's also well it's more
complex to interpret also but the
general idea would be that you have a
gene network here in one cell this is
impacting the mechanical properties of
the cell this is changing the shape of
the cell this is changing the shape of
the overall organs tissue and this in
turn because I'd grow in the other I
still got pressure raised mechanical
stress here this in turn could feed back
on the gene network and you realize but
at this point this is a mechanism that
is allowing the tissue or the cells to
know where they are all the tissue what
size it adds to it so it's sensing
mechanism for shape you know so if you
read mechanical signals you can know
your shape and then you can adjust you
can buffer your signs so you can do a
lot of things so that's let's say the
conceptual framework for this reading
shape thing and here I'm focusing on the
mechanical signals but of course there
are other signals too and we can do the
same feedback loop with biochemical
signals only I'm just saying that yeah
I'm looking at the contribution of
mechanical signals in this feedback loop
okay so the fact that there is
mechanical stress in this tissue can be
a bit mysterious so I just want to
classify this point with some very basic
images so if you have a bunch of rods
piled together now you put the thread
between both rods what happens here is
that this structure is stable its
metastable if you want so it's not going
to collapse it's it's there it looks
inert but actually what is in the
structure is a balance between tension
and compression so all the threads here
are under tension they're pulled and the
rods are under compression
so I want to simplify it and it's this
balance between tension and compression
that makes this structure stable so this
is very theoretical but it applies to
shapes and biology so if I take probably
the simplest shape you can imagine a
balloon or a sphere a balloon is a
stable shape but it's stable because
there is a gas inside that is under
compression and there is an unblock that
is under tension and it's the balance
between tension and compression that
allows the balloon to be stable in shape
you can also generate flat shapes with a
balance between tension and compression
so it is the kite example so you have
two rods under compression and the
membrane that is on the tension it's
pulled and with this balance you can
have flat shapes and of course we can
generate any shapes and that's what the
modern architecture is all about so I
don't know about the brutalist
architecture but any architecture you
can use this feature all right so all
this is for buildings so you could ask
the question whether it's applicable to
living organism and of course it is so
if you again an animal example but if
you if you go through a section of a
human femur
you see this pattern of trabeculae in
the in the film it's very intricate very
organized but you can also see that
there is a pattern it's not random and
if you cut several female you always see
this kind of overall pattern so now if
you calculate the pattern of stress of
mechanical stress in this tissue you see
here that there is a tension and if it's
compression it's basically the weight
that you put on your femur and what you
see also is that this pattern of stress
is matching the overall the pillars in
the in the females of the trabeculae or
in the orientation in the film so that
means that the bone is building to
resist to mechanical stress so you build
a pillar to resist in this case to
mainly to compression so it's it will be
like in the building you build a
vertical wall to resist gravity mmm okay
so this is for solid
in medium let's say so what we are
working on is soft really soft matter so
is this true also for soft matter answer
is yes so I take the example of the
stamina tile paper in 2011 what is
looked at is a mouse interesting at this
time and so you have this Wellspring
shape I would say like this second
quality the shape and so we want to know
what is there any forces in this
structure so what it did was an ilogger
analog model so here you put you take
two pieces of rubber you stretch one and
then you do you glue the two pieces
together and then you relaxed now what
you get is this so you get a structure
the shape of this structure is
relatively similar it's on the same
scale of course with the shape itself
the geometry is relatively similar to
this one so this is an indication that
maybe in this structure there is also a
balance between tension and compression
and that is what is generating this so
actually that's something you can even
feel when you do a dissection or mouse
and you get to the interesting looks
various bringing right so that fits with
this idea but the the best actually
demonstration is to do the reverse
experiment where you take your intestine
you you cut the tube and you cut the
Amazon tree so the two pieces and what
you see that the tube is expanding and
the middle tree is contracting so again
it reveals that there was a balance
between tension and compression in this
organ alright so I'm going to stop here
for the animals now I'm going to plants
so in plants it's the same idea and
actually in all living organism it's the
same as always the balance between
tension and compression I mean I should
never say always but usually there is a
balance between tension and compression
so yeah I'm just taking an example so
the radishes you can see example that I
like to use so if you do a radish salad
the first thing you do is that you cut
the radish and they pop open so will pop
open because the epidermis is on the
tension and the tissue inside is not a
compression it's also tough example is
the reverb so if you add rhubarb and you
peel
Yami's or the cortex of the ribbon and
you do that in water and to avoid the
dehydration you see that the context is
going to contract which means that it
wasn't the compression in the attention
before right for the attention we feed
it so it contracts alright so yeah I
just want to quote Cal's work here
because it's very important paper
summarizing this idea I'm going into
more detail to show that really it's the
epidermis usually in most tissues in
most plant tissues or iil tissues
usually but are under tension and this
has a primary role in growth and
opportunities for plants okay so now
into what we are doing more specifically
so here is just a scheme that I stole
from magic Gmail so this is a plant cell
already simplified scheme of a plant
cell so you have to go pressure inside
the cell wall is resisting to this
struggle pressure and you have the line
cellulose microfibrils
that are driving the direction of growth
of this cell which is orthogonal to the
cellulose microfibrils
I guess to this audience I don't know I
don't need to go into full details your
I guess all aware of this fact all right
so what is controlling the deposition of
the cellulose microfibrils what Gerry
accepted is that it's the Makah tributes
that are guiding the deposition of
cellulose in the cell wall so here you
have a piece of the plasma membrane the
cellulose Center is easier its extruding
cellulose inside the cell wall and just
beneath the plasma membrane you have two
cortical Mack tribute here and the
cellulose synthase is basically moving
along the microtubules so it's not
always true and there are exceptions but
in most tissues actually the more we get
data and live imaging data the more we
see this type of behavior so that's
really interesting for us because now we
can easily image microtubule dynamics
with GFP markers and we can can have an
indirect image of the deposition of
cellulose inside the cell wall and as
you may
understand cellulose is much more
difficult to image because it's inside
the cell wall we can't really put any
florescent marker for focus cellulose so
we have an indirect image of Civility
position and so we have an indirect
image of the mechanical properties of
the cell in a way because we know that
three laws is as stiff as still so we we
can have an idea of in which direction
does the cell wall is going to be
stiffer than over direction right we
have the mechanical anisotropy of the
cell wall with the orientation of the
microtubules okay so I'm going to start
with an example that we on which we
worked the past few years which is the
the payment cell so what you see the
young are a bit of this plant you have
two cotyledons
and if you look at the cotyledons you
see those cells at our intelligence
whatever jigsaw puzzle shape is the
matter so this is a typical shape form
epidermis it's not for all epidemics but
in our beliefs at least it's very clear
and this is actually a very well known
cell type I would say there's a lot of
experiments done on payment cell because
it's it's interesting your model and
something that we know is that we know
actually it's been characterized already
for the cytoskeleton and in particular
for the modules so when the cotyledon is
in the expansion phase so when it grows
at fast speed the Makah tubules within
one payment cell as a stereotypical
pattern in which you see those rings of
Maca tubules
between the necks of the payment cells
and in the lobes there is less max
tubules so it's sort of a bimodal
distribution if you want to you have a
lot of microtubules that are aligned in
the next and less in the lobes so of
course when you see that and if you feel
like the thyroid is going to be oriented
the same way here what we should see is
this right so you have a balloon you
have mo mega tubules so more cellulose
so you have a ring of cellulose
here and this could explain why you have
a jigsaw puzzle shape so there's only
indirect evidence so this is the case
there's been some staining for cellulose
for the mega tribute but no mechanical
measurements for the stiffness of
payments and so what we did was to adapt
atomic force microscopy to measure the
mechanical properties of those cells at
very high resolution so in in two words
atomic force microscopy in saturates
it's a sort of a old technique now but
it's been used a lot in material
sciences so you use your console ever
micrometric consider a little bit video
of a macrame tree with a nanometric tip
so here the little
the cantilever we use at the end the
radius is at 2 nanometer so it's really
small and we apply this cantilever on
the surface and with a laser we can
measure the curving or the deflection of
the cantilever so if the cantilever is
applied on a stiff surface it's going to
bend immediately if it's applied on a
soft surface is going to indent the
substrate and then is going to bend so
you can measure the delay in bending if
you want with the laser that's going to
be proportional to the stiffness of your
material and if you know the stiffness
of your cantilever when you can deduce
the material properties of your tissue
so of course here we use a very small
tip like 2 nanometer to only indent the
like a little bit of the cell wall and
just to have the local mechanical
properties of the cell wall okay so this
is the type of image we get so this is
we can get the topography of course
we've is images so you have here like
the boundary between two pavement cells
so you see again and the jigsaw puzzle
shape you have the curvature so at this
scale it's very very bumpy as you as you
can tell and it's actually I mean it's
smooth its bumpy but smooth in a way but
now if we get the force measurements so
the mechanical properties this is the
type of mat we get the map we get so
when it's white its stiff and when it's
black its soft so when it's also I
should do a make a little disclaimer
first
so the
really white zone or the really black
zone are probably artifacts or zones
that we can not really interpret because
it's too sloppy so we don't know what
we're doing so basically the cantilever
is intending on something at a certain
angle so it might slide we don't really
know what we're measuring so we prefer
to ignore both areas well if you focus
on the relatively flat part of the cell
you see those lines here so you see some
white line then some white line here you
have two that are matching the
microtubule pattern that we saw earlier
so in this case that would mean that
there is some wall reinforcement along
those lines between the next in those
cells
so let's if you want one evidence that
indeed those cells are reinforced along
those lines matching the predicted
cellulose deposition we have a positive
control which is the stomata so as you
may know in stomata the microtubules and
the cellulose is transverse and we see
also transverse stiffening in those
tissue okay so this model I mean which
it has been around this is conceptually
it's not new it's just more evidence
that it's true
let's see but of course now the question
is what is orienting the microtubule so
how come the microtubules are orienting
lobbies and relatively stable during
this fast-growing phase so one
possibility is that it's actually
mechanical stress but would orion was
max tubules and there are other
possibilities and I'm not saying it's
only mechanical stress but they are yeah
we want to test whether it's mechanical
stress that can orient those nitrogen
use so to do that to test this
hypothesis survival Kaminsky in the Anna
Johnson lab did the model in which she
could calculate the tension in the top
wall of those cells so basically you
have you take a cell you put you put
turgor pressure in it so you have a cell
wall that is under tension so if the
cell wall was last year it was just the
shape of a sphere the tension would be
the same in all direction so it would be
isotropic mechanical stress but because
here we start with a puzzle shaped cell
like this if you follow the red lines
which are the maximal tension lines you
see that they converge in the neck
regions and so this is the prediction of
the tension in though in this stop world
and you see that it's converging in
those necks and of course there is a
good match between the predicted maximal
tension line pattern and the orientation
of the Makah tubules
ok so ends the idea that maybe the
microtubules are able to sense some
obvious tension lines and align to
resist to this mechanical stress or to
unload the cellulose to resist with
mechanical stress ok so first you have
to show that there is tension in this
tissue so this is one movie to show that
so here you have cotyledon so you take
this tissue and what you do is you cut
it and it's a little bit like in the
robot experiment or in the radish
experiment if you cut it you should
reveal the pattern of stress in this
tissue so if you do that so here we've
removed a large part of the of the code
children when we when we cut it and what
you see is that it's it keeps open
opening after it's been cut so it means
that it is under tension indeed maybe I
should play it again
but this is not really a surprise right
I mean we've all we've seen before me
now is really accumulating evidence that
the epidermis is on the tension implant
issues so now we can do a model in which
we put the epidermis and attention and
we look at the pattern of stress in this
in this tissue and we're going to do an
ablation and predict the orientation of
the mechanical stress pattern after
ablation
so this is again what Pavel did so you
oblate
both cells here so you can forget about
the color code but if what you see is a
second front or orientation of the
stress here which makes sense right
I mean it's you you if you take a piece
of paper you cut it it's going to turn
to for it not to tell you need to
enforce it
so this is the the predicted pattern of
stress so now if you do it on the real
cotyledon that's what you see indeed so
you a blade large piece of the cotyledon
and you see this orientation of the
microtubules yeah so actually since then
we've tried to do this ablation at
different stages of the codon and there
is a good match between I mean this is a
good relation between the growth rate so
if you do that when the the codon is
real not really growing anymore you have
less of a response so you really need to
do this at the fast growing right which
makes sense right that's whether the
stress would be nice okay so this is
evidence that indeed the maca tribute
can reorient to align a long maximal
tension so of course there is over
experiment but I'm not going to show but
if you do compressions or if you do
family pharmacological treatments often
the cell wall for instance so to
increase the stress level you also see
the same type of reorientation of the of
the microtubules okay so the general
idea then is that a cell with its Mac
atribute is going to reinforce in cell
wall this is going to okay that's what
so this is a different color code but
the pink is okay so you reinforce the
cell wall this is controlling the cell
shape or stabilizing the cell shape if
you want and the shape itself is
prescribing a pattern of mechanical
stress that in turn is controlling the
microtubules right so in this case if
you start with your phaser shape you're
more likely to maintain a puzzle shape
it's not going to go to add a balloon
shape because of this feedback loop
anyway and so and this is a way to go
back to the reading shape idea yeah this
cell is able to read its own shape
through this mechanical feedback and to
amplify or to stabilize its shape
mechanical feedback loop okay so now if
we move at a larger scale so this is now
it dates back like a few years so we've
done some work in the in the shoot
apical meristem so this is an AR bit of
seeds again if you remove the flowers
when you get to this dome of cells
that's the shoot apical meristem
and the flowers are on the side so yeah
we use this system or you can do a lot
of things with the nice time but yeah we
will use the system as a mofo genetic
father in a way so this is a tissue with
a specific shape in a way the dome if
you fold in here and so we want to see
whether what we showed for the pavement
cell is also true for the milestone
so when you look at mac tubules in this
time so this is viewed from the top so
the center of the meristem would be here
this is a young Gauguin this is an older
organ and you see misalignments of Max
Tribune's here between the organ and the
main stem so again here and alignment of
macaron between the organ and the night
stem you also see this alignment of
microtubule below and this is
stereotypical so we always see this
pattern in the meristem this is really
like a constant thing each time you look
at them and the most time with a maximum
marker this is what you this is what you
would see so here again we can make the
analogy with the payment cell so you are
here the meristem especially in the
boundaries where you have an organ donor
stem and you have this alignment sweep
receiving our alignment from attribute
in the boundary looks a little bit like
in pigment cell where you also have
misalignment of microtubule between next
but here it's at the single cell level
and yeah it's a problem but if you found
if you forgot about the sub cell
division or the the cells it would be
basically the same so you have tangent
lines and the maccabees line again okay
so is this true so if you again assume
but the epidermis is on the tension you
can calculate the pattern of stress in
this tissue and what you find is that at
the top because it's a sphere the stress
is isotropic
there is no Direction no preferential
direction for the stem and it's a sign
under so the circumferential stress is
going to be twice I of and the actual
stress so this is well known in
engineering and the mechanics this is
for instance why the when you boil
sausages they are going to open
lengthwise because the stress in the
circumferential orientation is larger
than the actual stress so this is what
you would see here so if if the
epidermis is under tension the
the tension is going to be higher in the
second furniture orientation and in the
actual orientation and in the boundary
domain year so it's a bit of the mix
between this so it starts to be on the
side of the nice time so it starts to
become a bit more like this
but in addition you have an organ here
that is growing fast so because it grows
fast it's going to compress the cells
here so now you have compression in this
orientation and tension in that
orientation so in terms of tension it's
really really anisotropic very
directional so here you have a strong
tension in that orientation and of
course when you see this it's really
like in the femur what I showed you
earlier like the Thompson or the wall
flow on on femur you see that you have a
good match between the predicted pattern
of stress and your intention of the
ultimate abuse so again so we did a
number of experiment to change the
pattern of mechanical stress and see if
the mock tribute would reorient around
new stress pattern so I'm just going to
show one adjust the simplest one it's
easier so yeah it's an ablation so we
have again a model with the tension in
the on the top wall we do an ablation so
we predict a second financial
orientation so it's like in the column
it's exactly the same idea and so when
we do the experiment which has been done
by a marketer Eisler so here you have
the material the cell shape and this is
the major image you use a UV laser so
you burn to sell one or two cells so
this is what happens right afterwards
and then you let the McDougall reorient
and very orient second functionally
around the ablation so of course this is
not enough to fully proof that its
response to mechanical stress now is
wounding is lots of chemicals defined
use by wounding but if you do
compression you see the same and again I
mean you can do over experiment that
show that indeed each time you change
the stress pattern each time you change
the magnetic orientation also in the
meristem so basically what we're saying
is that it's a general rule in a way so
but when you have microtubules you're
going to change the shape via the effect
on ceelo's deposition but the shape
itself is going to prescribe the pattern
of mechanical stress that in turn is
to orient the mac attributes' so this is
in this case it's this feedback loop is
a way to read tissue shape
so here the tissue is able to read the
tissue folding add the my stem boundary
and amplify the folding so in this case
this feedback loop would help the organ
from like to move out of the nice time
domain so it would like visit me more
quickly separated physically separated
from the main stem with this feedback
loop okay so the problem with the of
course the feedback loop is that it's
sort of self maintained and so you
couldn't imagine that we've lost the
biology in this because what it's doing
its own thing so you just kick first and
then that's it it goes forever and you
don't have to do anything there's no
regulation which I mean it can be a done
an advantage in biology because you have
less control let's say but in biology we
usually like to see some regulation for
these things and especially because we
know that shape can be modulated by the
environment or the stage of development
so what could be the regulation for this
feedback loop so we've started to touch
upon this by looking at regulators of
microtubule dynamics and in particular
what we've found is that the catenin so
the catenin is a molecular scissors that
cuts the Micra tubules and increase the
magical dynamics and what we found is
that in a mutant for the catalan gene we
get a in protein we have a slower
marketable dynamics but we also have a
slower response to mechanical forces so
we could imagine that by playing with
catenin activity we could have a
feedback loop that is going to be more
more or less efficient and then you can
imagine that you can modify or modulate
the shape by modulating a katana but
again playing with this overall context
of the mechanical feedback loop okay and
we found also some interesting
consequences on graffiti rigidity but
i'm not going to go into
yeah another question we are for this is
to make a new transduction pathway so
how come I mean okay
how can a cell sense tension so there's
a lot of data known means a lot of data
in the animal systems there are make a
new transduction pathway that are
identified in animals there is formerly
no or maybe in there some indication in
plants about make a new transaction
pathways but there's no formal
demonstration of a full mechanical
injection pathway in plants so this is
an open area so yeah I'm just going to
pinpoint one maybe piece of data to show
whether what we found is that actually
making sense with what we know about the
max tubules in relation to stress so if
you what we know is that the max tubules
are extremely dynamic so they polymerize
to polymerize their caps all the time
and they can also zipper so we can
bundle with one another so this is the
standard situation so I'm actually
self-organized constantly and so that's
the way they can change orientation
quite quickly so now if you put that in
an isotropic environment well you you
might have more or less bundling but
this is not going to give you a
direction you need something to bias the
direction so how can we relate that to
tension there's been some data showing
that if you put a Mac attributed on the
tension you're going to promote the
polymerization of the max ubermann so
the microchip is going to polymerize
faster if you put the microtubule under
compression it's going to depolarize
actually going to depolymerize very very
quickly it's going to go through
catastrophe so it's going to just the
equity you can even see on movies in
front of your screen and you can see the
macula
really going away so it can be very
quick so if you add this in the mix of
the self-organization then it's logic
but the mock tribute would align along
the maximal tension right because you're
going to favor the Mac to build that
under tension and destroy if you want
the back to be that under compression
and it and since this is self organized
in a way you're going to have more and
more marketable bonding in the direction
of maximal tension
so this is based on data in animal cells
also in vitro so it seems it would be
something pretty general risk response
that is it makes sense that plant cells
would have used this for their response
okay so just to conclude I'm just going
to go back to the animal world just to
expand a little bit on this so this is
this idea that gene expression can be
impacted by mechanical forces is not new
and this is one of the few examples
where people have looked at this in a
multicellular context and this is in the
Drosophila embryo so here what you do is
what a manual first did was to indent
like to push on a number yo and you can
see that this gene in green twist is AK
topically expressed after this
compression so okay well this is the
very artificial I mean an orphan is a
drosophila embryo pushed by a micro
indenter is not too often in nature but
actually what what's interesting is that
this gene is expressed in domain but
during gastrulation is experiencing
compression so that means that maybe
during evolution there was there is
tissue movement especially during
gastrulation actually where you have
patterns again of compression and
tension and this can affect gene
expression so this is in drosophila but
actually more recently last year
actually showed the same thing in
zebrafish and what's spectacular here is
that so here you have the gastrulation
in a Drosophila so the cells are
compressed and you induce twists in
zebrafish
so this is AP body so what we did
equivalent you also have tissue movement
and you induce no tail which is would be
the equivalent of twist year through the
same make a note transduction pathway so
in this case it's a better kattiline
performance so it really shows that it
might be a very well conserved mechanism
in all living organism at least we can
say you know in to fillet that are very
very distant between the drosophila and
and the fish and also what's interesting
in this study and he is really going
beyond the state of the app is i mean
these
so twist and no tail and they are really
critical for miss Odom differentiation
and miss Odom differentiation that's
really big in animal development because
this is like well a lot of things are
derived from the the miss Odom people
have been looking for the the molecular
cue that would trigger a miss Odom the
differentiation and no one has found the
gene that would really be important from
a sudden differentiation and so what
Emmanuel is proposing is that it's
because we haven't found the gene
because it's a force and it's also of
course the odd genes involved but the
trigger the triggering event could be
this movement so of course this is like
the next boundary I guess alright so
with that I'll stop here so I have a
number of people to thank so in the team
in Lyon I'm working with our X cubed I
would with a theoretical physicist I so
the work I've showed was mainly done by
a benevolent huh asking me for the FM
and megabit well for the catenin
experiments we do a lot I mean we do a
little bit on on cell division with
Maruyama vas awesome modeling Annamayya
we'll do some people involve in imaging
here not now and Mathilde ein hawd in
the in the simple analysis project with
a dream and we child so I haven't talked
at all about the simple I thought we had
talked a lot this weekend in a workshop
so but is some interesting a data coming
up soon
I would say from the Visconti ostium the
work on payments L was done in
collaboration with the team of energy
Johnson and Elliot Meyerowitz
and this overall project actually was
initiated by issue there again
theoretical physicist and yantras right
thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu